[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today James
starts this hour in Canada hi James how
are
you I'm doing very well better than I
deserve how are you Dave better than I
deserve sir what's
up this is an honor to talk to you I am
such a fan of the show well I'm honored
to talk to you how can we
help uh just I just have a quick well
not a quick question me and my wife are
are planning to get out of that as soon
as possible and I just have a question
that's been lingering on my mind I have
uh some Investments about $5,000
Canadian in uh some
ETFs and I'm just wondering if I should
sell my investments to pay off DE okay
what kind of debt have you
got I have a line of credit that's about
$199,000 uh we also have some credit
card debt and uh and a c as well how
much do you ow how much do you owe on
your credit
cards uh my credit card itself is about
$133,000 okay so there's a there's an
old rule that I've learned I've Twisted
it around a little bit and used the rule
because it's a
decision-making uh framework that's
helped me a bunch it comes from the
Harvard investment
newsletter and um the guy in there says
when you've made a bad when you made an
investment and let's say you bought a
stock at $100 a share and it went down
to $75 a share okay and so you're about
to lose you know you're going to lose
money if you sell it while it's down but
you really don't think it's ever going
to come up it's not it's not it's a
crummy company it's probably going to go
on down but you're waiting on it to at
least come back to where what you paid
for it his point is what you paid for it
doesn't matter all that matters is the
future of the stock from $75
what's it going to do go up or down and
his what he says is don't analyze it
based on what you paid for it that's
called a sunk cost analysis now I'm
that's an investment process now I'm I
flip that and I use it in situations
like yours or other situations like I'm
in as well sometimes if you own
something and you reverse engineer it it
tells you what you should do instantly
let me give it to you in this way let's
pretend you didn't have $113,000 in
credit card debt but you had $8,000 in
credit card debt would you and you did
not have a $5,000 ETF would you go buy
an borrow an additional 5,000 on your
credit cards to invest into an ETF well
crud
no no no I mean we can answer that
instantly can't we that sounds stupid
when you say it that way doesn't it but
all that is is the reverse of your
question so if you would not borrow
5,000 more on your credit cards in order
to buy an ETF we would instantly cash
out the ETF to pay 5,000 down on the
credit cards because it's the same
difference just
backwards yeah that's you know what when
you say it like that it's very very
obvious it's kind of like sometimes we
get we get we get paralyzed by these
decision makings because we're stuck in
the moment rather than in the reverse
you can do it with a boat if you got a
boat sitting in the driveway that's
worth $10,000 you go if I had $10,000 in
the middle of my kitchen table would I
go buy a boat just like that if I didn't
have that boat well crud no we had used
the thing in 5 years I'm tired of it
takes up space I'm paying insurance on
it I it's it's it's going down in value
or we use it every weekend the kids love
that boat of course I would go buy that
boat if I had $10,000 and I didn't have
that boat well then you keep the boat
then but if you go well no I would never
buy that boat again then it's way past
time to sell that boat right you you
just reverse engineering and it tells
you what to do in these situations Ken
does it with a job don't you I mean you
could go and go I hate my job well if
you didn't have this job today would you
take this job Lord no then why are you
still working there you know true yeah
yeah people say should I stay or should
I go and I said well uh just the fact
that you're answering the question yeah
we need to go yeah you wouldn't stay if
if I had a job waiting for you today so
that's absolutely right it's a great
great analogy yeah so that that's how
I'm going to tell you um and and but
more importantly is the why or how the
process we used to make the decision
James it tells us instantly with a
little bit of reverse engineering now uh
um you know that's why we tell people
not to take money out of a retirement
plan because there's a big
penalty and a big tax in order to put
the money into your credit card it's
going to hit you in in the states it
would hit you about 40% between
penalties and taxes so that's like
saying Dave would I borrow 40% borrow
money at 40% interest to pay down on my
debt well crap no that's dumb we're not
doing doing that and so same that that
that's why we tell you not to cash out
retirement but yes to cash out the ETF
yeah makes a lot of sense and in this
case huge momentum coming out of this
decision as well you know you know I
think Ken the the great resignation that
we just came through after the fouchy
pandemic everybody quit their jobs
because they wanted to have a better
life yeah um was caused a little bit by
that but even the great regret by people
wishing they didn't quit their jobs uh
is also caused by that isn't it it's all
this it's all this it was more emotion
driven impulse driven than it was
thinking okay I don't want to live this
way that's exactly right well we're
trying to get the Quick Fix and the
Quick Fix was I'm going to leave a
company where I'm valued and I actually
enjoy the work and I'm going to go over
here for a 15% raise then they got there
and it wasn't what they thought and the
raise wore off the high you know there's
a decision like oo I make a decision and
I get ahead quick you feel like you've
gained the system then they're there for
3 months that's play sucks and that's
what you call the great regret and by
the way what Dave talking about folks is
we're talking about millions of workers
millions millions who said I wish I had
stayed at my previous company this is
not like a little Trend this was a major
wave of people and again we were trying
to game the system and get the Quick Fix
and you realize oh I would have been
better off staying where I am I'd be
happier more fulfilled and that affects
my my anxiety depression which affects
my sleep my physical life my
relationship life with my wife my kids
if I'm dragging all that crap from work
home with me uh and I didn't get that
much of a behavior change and to this
point if you took a 15% raise to try to
pay off credit card debt or to pay off
well I can live more and you just kept
spending and by the way Dave that's what
we've seen right now in our economy we
just got the latest reports out the GDP
is up because the consumers in America
are spending like Congress and credit
card debt is going up with it and we've
got to take control of our spending take
control of our habits and getting out of
debt back to this call uh and not just
chasing the next big thing it's the
discipline to say I'm going to change my
life change the way I act and those are
going to guide my decisions not the next
big Quick Fix to feel like I just gained
the system you got to change who you are
more money to get in a worse place wears
off in about 20 minutes really fast yeah
you get a career hangover from that one
yeah and then you try to drown it out
with credit card
debt ow funny how not James James is
going to pay down his CR with an ETF